so I asked 9 ona Thompson how his
ancestors were able to navigate so well
by the Stars all right so let's check it
out so you guys must have known the
stars really well and I mean I use my
tools to remind me where they rise and
sat and where to expect them but if you
don't have the tools then it's in you
somehow and then you navigate with them
so how do you do that
ok I mean one issues that even be able
to identify and pick out stars and
memorize that it's a specific thoughts
of identification because a star
isolated is nothing there's a context a
pattern that you have to pattern
recognition letters right yeah but
because you can find the star in the sky
doesn't tell you anything about
navigation you need to know primarily
where it rises and sets okay
and so there is this mental construct
called the star compass star compass I
like that it's as if you're a satellite
looking down at the oceans horizon and
there's a canoe in the center of this
big circle and a circle is that that
circle that's a circle
all right here we go and it's divided
into 32 star houses maybe north is here
South series is here West is there
there's 7 star house there meaning each
quadrant ok uh-huh and so let's say this
is the eastern horizon so you can take a
star and identify it but you need to
know what star houses it is like Mintaka
in Orion's belt rises due east comes
across the sky and sets due west or any
of the stars right okay so you so you've
split this the perimeter the the horizon
into these places if you can identify
the star and if you know what star house
it rises in in you can hold direction
mmm so if you wanted to go east you go
straight towards been talking that'd be
easy right okay you wanted to go west
you go straight away from in talks at
any place in between you know the rest
of the stars to make that happen you
line them up on pieces of wood and the
Kanodia
there's actually a canoe compass that is
on a deck that that
makes of 32 houses so we actually if you
have a star compass we're turning the
canoe compass in the star compass and
lining up different stars of different
parts of the canoe to hold the desired
heading
you